You would think the smell would be the
worst part. And don’t get me wrong,
it was far from pleasant, to say the least.
That pungent odor, a stomach-turning scent
like raw sewage. It wasn’t just dirt and decay;
no, it was far more disgusting than that. It had
that awful metal tang to it, that meant when
the awful stench crawled its way up your nose,
it lingered, hanging at the back of your throat,
choking you on the sickening reek that lay thick
in the air like a foul-smelling fog.
And yet, like I said, that was far
from the worst part. What was? Well, even the
sight of what had happened to him wasn’t what
made me feel unsettled. Hardly any of his
body was visible, covered in that writhing,
shifting cloak. But I could see it move, each
tiny piece of the mass moving on its own.
It made me imagine what it must have felt like, to
have all those little scratchy legs and pincers,
claws, and teeth hooking into his skin. And that,
the idea of what it would feel like… that was
the worst part about seeing the Vermin God.
City life isn’t really all it’s cracked up
to be. Ask anyone who lives in a big urban
area and they’ll likely tell you the same.
Those bright lights and tall spires reaching up to
the clouds, they offer the promise of prosperity,
opportunity, and even fame and fortune for those
who are extra naïve. But when they upped sticks,
packed their bags, and moved here to start a
new life, they realized that all along they
had been sold on a dream, a false fantasy
that is just simply too good to be true.
Of course, by the time they get here it’s
already too late, and before they know it,
they’re knee-deep in debt, trying to keep up with
paying rent on an apartment that’s barely big
enough for one person. If you aren’t careful, a
big city can swallow you up, sometimes literally.
Never mind just desperately trying to
make ends meet and keep yourself afloat,
there’s also plenty of danger to be found in the
heart of the city. It doesn’t take much for people
to lose themselves in the darker parts of this
metropolitan hell pretending it’s a haven. And
when they do, that’s usually where my job starts.
I had been working as a Private Investigator for
coming up on a decade. My specific job title had
gone through a number of rebrands and different
combinations of terms over the years; Cassius
Duke, Detective-for-Hire, then ‘Private Eye’,
and ‘Freelance Investigator’ after that. And don’t
fall under the same sort of assumptions that most
people do when they hear all those terms; believe
me, just like the city’s promises, it rarely
lives up to what you’d imagine it to be like. My
life was never high-speed chases and gunfights,
solving murders, and tracking down crooks that
robbed banks in clown masks. That was work for
the ‘real’ police, allegedly much higher
above my pay grade now that I had quit.
Most of the time I dealt with uncovering the
various dirty little secrets this grimy city
had to offer. More often than not, my job was
working as either a spy or enforcer that anyone
could hire. I followed around the rivals of
wealthy businessmen, snapping photos of them
with my camera to get any dirt I could, that my
more unethical clients would probably use for
blackmail. Or, I’d be warning stalkers to keep
away from whoever they were causing trouble for,
usually with a bit of ‘gentle encouragement’
in the form of some pretty stern words and
a rap on the knuckles of sorts. It
was ugly work, but that suited just
how ugly the underside of this whole city was.
Some of my clients were often desperate people,
folks who the ordinary system of law and
order had failed. When that happened,
when they had been turned away by the cops,
on the verge of losing any hope they had left,
that was usually when they turned to me for help.
Now, I didn’t work for free, of course;
you get nothing for nothing, everything’s got its
price, so on and so forth. But I wasn’t looking to
extort people, especially at their lowest moments.
So, firm but fair, I’d charge them a little bit
for my time, maybe a finder’s fee if I happened
to come across some dirt that was really worth
some extra cash. It was rare for me to take on a
job ‘pro bono’ as it were, without expecting any
pay for my services. But when this case landed in
my lap, I felt obligated to do the job for free.
It was another grey day in a grey city. A knock on
the door interrupted me from my busy schedule of
staring at the paint flaking off my ceiling. After
I’d called them through, the person responsible
for that knock came stepping cautiously into my
office. He told me his name was Martin Jenkins,
but that his friends called him Marty.
“Sorry, I don’t really know how all this
works,” Martin admitted, making no
attempt to mask how nervous he was.
“Well, why don’t you take a seat
first?” I sighed. “That’s a start.”
“Oh, okay,” he replied, awkwardly pulling up
a chair and sitting down opposite my desk.
“So, Mr Jenkins, what can I-”
“Marty,” he interjected.
“Mr Jenkins,” I repeated. “What
is it that brings you here?”
“Well, someone said you might be able to help
with my… problem?” Martin said sheepishly.
“And what sort of problem are you having, Mr
Jenkins?” I pushed for him to give me a straight
answer; I didn’t really have a lot of patience for
anyone who wasted time just getting to the point.
“It’s my brother, you see. The other Mr
Jenkins,” he finally confessed. “He’s
been missing, it’s actually been months now.”
“A missing person’s case is a police matter, I’m
sorry, but you’ll have to go to them.” As bad as
it felt turning the guy down at a time like this,
I had my profession to protect; if I wasn’t
careful, the cops would come down on me like a ton
of bricks. I’d already ruffled up some feathers
in that area; not long before, I had taken a
case wherein I’d accidentally photographed
some corrupt officers accepting bribes.
Once those pictures wound up on the evening news,
there had been a target on my back ever since.
“But, Detective Duke-” Martin began to say.
“Mister Duke,” I corrected him.
“I’ve already tried going to the police. They
wouldn’t even accept it as a missing persons case
when I explained what happened to my brother.”
“Go on,” I said, reaching for my notebook
and a pen on the desk.
“I left the city a while
ago after my brother and I – Melvin, his
name’s Melvin Jenkins – we had an argument.”
“And what was it that triggered this argument?”
I asked, dragging my pen across the page.
“It was… well, a lot of things,” Martin
sighed. “Our father died almost a year ago,
it wasn’t unexpected, but Mel took it pretty
hard. Then, the doctors told us the condition
dad had carried a chance of being hereditary.
So, we both went to get tested. I didn’t show
any signs of developing it, but Melvin did.
He took it as a death sentence, got very low,
and started wasting all of our inheritance on
every vice he could get his hands on. Drinking,
partying, gambling; you name it, he was doing it.”
“And this led to the argument?” I probed.
“It did. I confronted him before I left town,
I was mad that he’d been using all our dad left
us for such frivolous and irresponsible things,”
Marvin continued his story, almost unable to stop
now he’d started. “He didn’t want to hear any of
it, said he was going to die eventually anyway
so what was the point. Then, I told him he was
selfish, and that was the last time we spoke.”
“When did you notice he was missing?”
“Soon as I came back from out of town,”
he answered. “I went to the apartment –
dad had left us that too, along with all
the payments still due – and I found that
Mel was gone. Apparently, he had bet it in
a card game and lost badly. I had no way of
finding him, nobody else knew where he was.”
“Let me guess,” I stepped in.
“When you went to the police,
they said he’s most likely living on the streets,
which would make him a lot harder to find.”
Martin nodded solemnly, clearly feeling guilty
for what had happened, although from where I
was sitting, it was his brother’s own misgivings
that had created this situation. I went on to ask
a few more background questions, before asking
if Mister Jenkins could provide me with a photo
of his missing brother. He obliged, handing
over a printed picture. The moment I saw it,
I offered to take the case for free.
His brother, Melvin, I recognized him almost
instantly. He was in his mid, or possibly late
thirties, average height and build in the picture;
far better shape and a lot cleaner than
when I’d seen him. But it was the same guy,
that much I was sure of, no amount of
unshaved stubble or disheveled clothing
could change that. I had seen him – seen
Melvin – outside my building a few times,
sleeping rough on the sidewalk. Every day that I
showed up to start another day of work, I’d drop
him a few dollars, anything I had in my wallet.
At first, I told myself it was for good luck, so I
didn’t attract any bad karma for myself. But when
I actually paid attention to how he was living,
the gesture became what it should have been from
the start. It wasn’t about me, or sparing myself
bad luck, it was just about trying to help out
someone who needed it, when I was in a position
to do him a small kindness at the very least.
One night, I’d just locked up my office and
was about to head home. As I stepped off the
curb, head down, eyes on my phone, a truck came
speeding down the street. I would have been killed
instantly had a hand not grabbed me and pulled my
back onto the sidewalk. Melvin had hauled me out
of harm’s way. He didn’t say anything to me, and I
failed to do any more than just thank him verbally
before heading him. So, I figured I owed him one.
While I didn’t tell his brother this, it had
been a few months since I’d last seen Melvin
outside my building. I’d always assumed he’d moved
on, or been asked to move by an overzealous cop.
Of course, that meant figuring out where he
was going to be tricky, exactly the reason
the police had turned Martin away when he’d
asked them for help locating his brother. But
I had a few connections that, even if they hadn’t
seen Melvin, might have at least heard something,
or could know someone else that had seen him.
It wasn’t a lead yet, but it was a start.
Dee was the head of the city’s biggest
homeless shelter, and a good friend of mine.
So, she became my first port of call. I showed
her the photo of Melvin, and asked if he’d come
to stay at the shelter at all recently.
“Doesn’t ring a bell, I’m afraid.”
She looked sombrely at the picture.
“Sorry, Duke, I wish I could be more help.”
“Not on you,” I replied, taking the photo as she
handed it back to me. “You mind if I ask around?
See if anyone here recognizes him?”
“Be my guest,” Dee said.
I spent about an hour milling around, asking
a few down-on-their-luck folks if they
recognized the man in the photo. A few of them
mentioned they’d seen him around here and there,
sleeping rough in a number of different parts of
the city but none of them could give me anything
concrete, no definite location I’d be able to
search next. That was until one of them spoke
up. He was an older guy, bedabbled clothes and
unwashed hair, with a thick beard, who had been
craning his neck to try and sneak a look at
the photo when I’d been showing someone else.
“I’ve seen him,” the man –
Clarence – said matter-of-factly.
“You recognize this man?” I asked to verify.
“Said I seen him,” he repeated.
“Looks different now though.”
“Well, that’s to be expected,” I replied.
“I don’t just mean he’s gotten
skinnier because he ain’t been eating,”
Clarence said in retort. “I mean that he
don’t even look like he’s human no more.”
“What does that mean?” I questioned, looking
back at the bearded man in confusion.
“That man right there stopped being a man. No idea
when or how it happened. But last time I saw him,
it was already too late.
Nowadays, he’s the Vermin God.”
I didn’t really have much idea how to respond,
unsure if Clarence was pulling my leg and
deliberately wasting my time, or if there
was some truth to this bizarre urban legend.
At any rate, it was the only lead I had so far,
albeit a tenuous one at best. So, I pressed the
old man to tell me where he’d seen Melvin,
of this ‘Vermin God’ as he kept calling him.
“There’s an abandoned warehouse down on the
waterfront,” Clarence had explained; I knew the
place he meant, it used to be a go-to for people
who were sleeping rough. “Lot of us used to stay
there, but that’s when the pests got bad.”
“Pests? What kind of pests?”
“All kinds. Rats, roaches, you name it. Then,
just as we were having to deal with them,
the company that owned the building sent cops
down to clear us out, told us it was unsafe and
we should move on. It was sitting there, empty for
ages, so I decided to chance it, head down there
and see if we could start using the place again.
But when I went to look… he was there. Waiting
in the dark. And he wasn’t alone, he ain’t ever
alone, they’re always with him, all around him.”
I chose to ignore Clarence’s attempts at unnerving
me, getting him to confirm once again that it was
in fact Melvin he had seen. My next call was
following up on the wild story, so I hopped
on the next bus across town, huddled together
with commuters, holding on to ceiling rails,
swaying about with every turn of the bus like we
were meat hanging in the back of a butcher’s van.
I walked quite a way from the bus stop towards
the docks. Most of the area was restricted,
off-limits to members of the general public given
how hazardous it could be. I wasn’t concerned,
in my line of work I usually had to get into
places I wasn’t supposed to be. Pulling a pair
of wire cutters from my jacket pocket, I snipped
through the chain-link fence that surrounded the
warehouse Clarence had directed me to. The place
wasn’t guarded, after all, it was empty. Lifting
up the wire mesh and slipping underneath through
the gap, I grabbed my flashlight and headed in.
The warehouse was well and truly deserted,
previously used for storage but now just an empty
space that was being left vacant, wasted in its
lack of use. All around was silence, occasionally
broken by beads of water dripping from the
skylight into a puddle on the ground. Suddenly
I heard a new noise, a crunch of something
being squashed under the sole of my shoe. I
lifted my foot and shone my torchlight downwards,
looking to see what it was I’d just stepped on.
It was a cockroach, far bigger and fatter than
any I’d ever seen, smashed to pieces underneath
my shoe. I stamped the rest of it off, a little
disgusted as everyone gets when they see a roach,
dead or alive. That’s when I noticed
another sound, a low, dull buzzing. My
initial thought was that it was electrical,
maybe a generator that was still running. I
started searching around for the source of the
sound, thinking that if I could flip the switch,
it might turn on some lights in here which
would make searching for Melvin a little easier.
Suddenly, as I turned a corner, the buzzing sound
got louder. It wasn’t just closer it was… angrier,
more intense. What was worse was that I’d
walked directly into a cloud of something, or
lots of somethings. Tiny flies were whizzing
past my ears, the noise of their wings so
close it was almost deafening. Meanwhile,
even more, were zipping around my face,
landing on my skin and rubbing their little
germ-coated legs together. Waving my arms wildly,
I tried my best to disperse the swarm, clearing a
few of them away as I tumbled into the next room.
My flashlight clattered to the floor, and
I crawled over to pick it back up, blindly
swatting more of the insects away in the dark.
That’s when I saw him. The Vermin God.
With no light in the room, only the beam from
my flashlight, I hadn’t noticed it at first.
The second the light fell over the writhing mass,
it shifted. As a matter of fact, it didn’t stop
moving, not once. It was a seething assortment of
vermin, mostly black rats, their fur wet with what
I could only assume was water straight from the
sewer. But there was more; worms, huge spiders,
thick roaches dropping off of the huge shape as
it turned. It stood up, a mass of animals and
insects standing like a man, lumbering towards
me. Creatures were falling off with every step,
only to crawl back in and join the rest.
I pushed myself back on the floor,
trying to get away from what I assumed to be
a horrific monster. Something controlling all
the rats and vermin, making them form
around it like a cloak of pure filth
and decay. The stench of it as well, the foul,
unclean smell hanging in the air and lingering
at the back of my throat made me want to be sick.
It was so repugnant that it kept me crawling back,
until my back was pressed up against the
wall, trapping me between it and the Vermin
God. It leaned closer, reaching out an arm,
covered in grime and cockroaches all crawling
over each other. I turned away and closed my eyes,
yelling out into the dark for anyone to come and…
“Help,” a voice said weakly.
I looked up at it, panting and shaking in fear.
With trembling fingers, I lifted my flashlight
higher, right up to the head of the Vermin God.
Beneath the mass of rats crawling over it,
and the bugs wriggling about below them,
a pair of eyes glinted in my flashlight’s beam…
human eyes. They were eyes I’d seen before,
the same hopelessness behind them as when he
used to ask for change outside my building.
It was Melvin. That’s when I started to
see beneath the vermin coating his body,
catching brief glimpses of his arms and chest,
just as one rat moved but before another slipped
in and took its place. His skin was pockmarked
with bites and scratches, some fresh and still
bleeding, others that had started to dry. Beneath
the shroud of crawling insects and rodents,
his face had gotten gaunt, coated in a thick
layer of dirt. He wasn’t controlling these things,
if anything the vermin seemed to
be using him as some kind of host.
Just as I edged a little closer to him,
considering the idea of reaching into the mass
and pulling Melvin free, one of the rats bit me.
I dropped my torch at the pain of the tiny needly
teeth piercing my skin and started to feel more of
them crawling up my ankles. I turned heel and ran,
all the way out of the warehouse.
By the time I was far enough away,
the rats that had leapt onto me had crawled back
off, heading back inside to their Vermin God.
Now go and check out “SCP-1025
ENCYCLOPEDIA OF COMMON DISEASES”
and “SCP-3760 LIKE A DOLL’S EYE” for more
sickening stories of other anomalous illnesses
that are guaranteed to make your skin crawl…
or maybe that’s just the rats you’re feeling…